veamos qué sucede con las expresiones
algebraicas que incluyen multiplicación
de fracciones supongamos que tenemos
sobre b
se sobre
de aquí es igual esto te invito a que le
pongas pausa el vídeo e intentes hacerlo
por tu cuenta bien al multiplicar
fracciones simplemente se multiplican
los numeradores y se multiplican los
denominadores los numeradores son aice
así es que al multiplicarlo resulta que
el numerador es a porsche que se escribe
simplemente hace y eso sobre el
denominador que es el producto debe por
de resultando en b x
ve por de qué pasaría si estuviéramos
dividiendo en vez de multiplicando en
este caso tendríamos a
sobre b
/
/ / se sobre de esto a que es igual
nuevamente te invito a que le pongas
pausa el vídeo e intentes hacerlo por tu
cuenta bien cuando haces la división
entre una fracción eso equivale a la
multiplicación por su recíproco
así es que esto es igual a
sobre d
sobre
el recíproco de sé sobre de qué
sobre deja de poner lo mejor con el
mismo color que tiene originalmente de
sobre sí
aso breve bordes sobre si así como
arriba de hecho no debería haber usado
este símbolo pues esto ahora que estamos
en álgebra se puede confundir con una
equis lo voy a indicar con un punto como
se hace en álgebra así es que a sobre b
que multiplica a d sobre c y esto es
igual a como ya sabemos esto es igual
d
sobre
sobre b
hagamos otro hagamos otro digamos un
poco más complicado y veamos si tú
puedes resolverlo supongamos que tenemos
no se deja de escribirlo como uno sobre
a
- 1 sobre b y todo eso sobre ce y vamos
a complicar un poco más la expresión y
eso vamos a dividir lo vamos a dividirlo
entre 1 sobre d es una expresión más
complicada que las que ya hemos visto
pero ya contamos con los elementos para
resolverla te invito a que le pongas
pausa el vídeo ideas si puede resolver
esto para obtener una sola expresión
equivalente bien hagámoslo paso a paso
empecemos con uno sobre a menos 1 sobre
b calculemos primero cuál es el valor de
esta expresión ya sabemos cómo
simplificar esto empecemos encontrando
el común denominador
hagámoslo acá arriba tenemos 1 sobre a
menos 1 sobre b y esto es igual
empezamos aquí multiplicando por b tanto
el numerador como el denominador para
obtener b sobre b entre a no he cambiado
el valor de un entre a lo x ver sobre b
y aquí vamos a multiplicar por el
numerador y el denominador nos va a dar
menos
sobre ave o vea y la razón por la que
hice esto es tener un común denominador
para poder hacer la diferencia esto es
igual a b menos a sobre y el denominador
lo puede escribir como vea o ave así es
que esto va a ser igual a esto es igual
a 1 entre a menos 1 entre de acabamos de
ver que es venenosa sobre ave y esto lo
tenemos que dividir en 13 lo cual es lo
mismo que multiplicar por el recíproco
de c dividir en 13 es lo mismo que
multiplicar por el recíproco de c que es
igual a 1 en 13 y aquí continuando con
el desarrollo tenemos una división entre
1 entre de lo cual fíjate aquí tuvimos
una división entre c que fue lo mismo
que multiplicar por 1 entre c
ahora tenemos una división entre 1 entre
d que es lo mismo que multiplicar por el
recíproco de d
así es que esto
de sobre 1
y esto es igual a en el numerador
tenemos el producto de de menos a por
uno y por de que es igual a de que
multiplica a
de menos a de que multiplica de menos a
y en el denominador tenemos a por b por
c así es que entre a
ve
finalmente vamos a aplicar aquí la
propiedad distributiva para este
producto de de borde menos a
así es que esto es igual y aquí yo creo
que merecemos una pequeña fanfarria esto
es igual a d
que multiplica a d
- d
no lo va a poner con el mismo verde - d
ahora y eso / / a
por ver
y así hemos concluido